the u.s will send another 270 million
dollars in military aid to help ukraine
in its five-month battle with russia the
white house says this will include drone
support consideration is being given to
possibly send fighter aircraft as well
this comes as russia and ukraine managed
to find common ground friday signing two
separate agreements to allow ukraine to
resume shipments of grain across the
black sea as russia lifts its naval
blockade but this morning russian
missiles are reportedly striking the key
port city of odessa holly williams has
the latest from
excuse me dunny pro in central ukraine
holly good morning
good morning well russia's been accused
of using hunger as a weapon of war by
blockading ukraine's ports contributing
to a dangerous spike in food prices
around the world now this new deal could
avert a global food crisis but it's
fragile and now less than a day later
ukraine says one of its ports has been
hit with cruise missiles calling it a
spit in the face to the u.n secretary
general
the russians and ukrainians refused to
sit at the same table and avoided
shaking hands but this deal could hold
off disaster in some of the world's
poorest countries it will bring relief
for developing countries on the edge of
bankruptcy and the most vulnerable
people on the edge of famine
more than 20 million tons of grain have
been stuck in ukraine and the war has
destroyed silos and crops contributing
to a surge in food prices the united
nations says 345
million people many in africa are now
marching to the brink of starvation
before the invasion ukraine was one of
the world's biggest exporters of grain
the breadbasket of europe
russia's blockade has been called a war
crime by the european union
though russia denies its weaponized
hunger
this however is irrefutable the deadly
violence unleashed by vladimir putin's
invasion
on thursday this woman lost her husband
when a crowded market was hit by
shelling but much-needed weapons are
arriving from the u.s and its allies
and they're making a difference
this week the u.s promised more highmar
rocket systems with a 50-mile range
they're game-changing according to
ukraine the ukrainians are making the
russians pay for every inch of territory
that they gain the u.s says russian
forces have only advanced six to 10
miles in eastern ukraine in the last 90
days these tactical gains have come at
an incredible cost
in terms of russian casualties and
destroyed equipment
ukraine's president vladimir zelansky
said in an interview this past week that
back in may and june his military was
losing up to 200 soldiers every day and
that's now down to 30. meanwhile the
head of britain's foreign intelligence
service predicts that russia's assault
is about to quote run out of steam after
some epic fails
jeff holly thank you very much